hey guys Ryan right here um I'm actually
pretty stoked to watch this next trailer
it's for the game hatred you guys can
check out my previous reaction to it I
was so shocked by what I was watching as
time has passed I do want to pick up the
controller and shrug it out just to the
part taken just out brutal this game and
yep that is it is bad nothing can stop
my age ridicule what breeds within you
[Music]
a fearless remorseless genocide machine
old and deliberate
Wow
sacrificing their lives
to protect the innocent
[Music]
human shields
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to your nightmare [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] man I've been going through a lot
lately I know what it's like to feel a
lot of anger sometimes on a lot of
hatred so I don't know I can't partake
in this game a little bit I don't feel
like going on a murderous rampage you're
like annihilating a bunch of innocent
people but I'm gonna sound so [ __ ] up
for saying that's it it looks kind of
funny I just the fact that you could
like destroy gas stations go into
people's homes and it's like the sins
but with violence it looks like so
[ __ ] insanely like one thing I like
is how they are actually including like
sort of villains the police but it's
kind of interesting to play as this bad
guy serial killers like this and movies
are always interesting to watch it's a
little scary to get pulled into the game
like this and be the bad guy honestly
sometimes you just got a coma murderers
rampage in a game let's face it Grand
Theft Auto sure it's not about that but
you can do all that [ __ ] and Grand Theft
Auto and it's pretty interesting to see
that that is the goal here to murder as
many innocent people as possible I'm not
gonna say the exact location but there's
this one Denny's I know of where I I
wouldn't mind if all them died and I
hope they can include a Denny's inside
of this game not the customers just the
workers but if the customers are there
then yeah they sorry you guys are gonna
get killed too rating time I will
definitely be playing hatred
[Music]
anyway guys thanks for telling me that
was out
I am so intrigued if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
trying to get product placement by
posting a photo of like a coca-cola can
um pornhub.com if you're listening I'm
willing to help it out Russell Johnson
could actually read this comment hey
guys just wanted to say I've been a
longtime subscriber and that you're my
favorite channel on YouTube although I
really think you guys should kick out
that Ryan douche he always makes it seem
like he runs things and that he's the
owner of the channel or something what a
psycho okay Russell Johnson first off
you can suck my Russell Johnson I'm sure
you got that a lot for what I wanted to
say though is I hope you're featured in
the hatred game what I'm specifically
hoping for is that I don't just get a
murder you but that I can capture you in
torture you for weeks on end and tear
you apart limb by limb til you're
breathing up from just your head you
know I want to take off your penis and
then shove it down your mother's mouth
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you I might have
gotten a little too offended I am sorry